wir bekommen oft die frage von euch ob
auch deutsche im deutschen manchmal
fehler machen
das ist tatsächlich ein großes thema
dass wir noch mal in einem eigenen video
erörtern werden denn die frage ist
tatsächlich was ist ein sogenannter
fehler was aber häufig vorkommt sind
tatsächlich fehler im schriftlichen
deutsch die schriftsprache ist ja quasi
eine dokumentation der tatsächlich
gesprochenen sprache und in dieser
schriftsprache gibt es regeln und diese
regeln kennen tatsächlich auch viele
deutsche nicht ein typischer fehler oder
vielleicht der häufigste fehler den
deutsche in der schriftlichen sprache
machen ist die verwechslung von das mit
einem ass und das mit zwei s und das ist
tatsächlich ein problem dass viele von
euch auch haben
im deutschen gibt es drei varianten von
dem wort das und die erklären wir euch
heute das erste was ihr zu dem thema das
wissen solltet ist dass es tatsächlich
drei verschiedene varianten gibt es gibt
einmal das als artikel das mit einem ass
als artikel dann gibt es das als
pronomen wird auch mit einem es
geschrieben und dann gibt es auch noch
das als konjunktion und diese
konjunktion wird im deutschen mit zwei s
geschrieben und jetzt stellen wir euch
alle drei formen einmal im detail vor
die erste variante von das ist das als
artikel wie ihr wisst haben alle nomen
im deutschen einen artikel der die oder
das und der neutrale artikel heißt
einfach das und steht vor einem nomen
das wetter das auto das kind das handy
artikel sind manchmal etwas nervig zu
lernen für euch aber ja die gute
nachricht ist dass man es einfach lernen
kann wie eine vokabel in unserer apps
haben wir dafür zum beispiel einen
gender trainer gebaut um das etwas
spielerischer zu machen wenn ihr den mal
ausprobieren wollt findet ihr hier oben
einen link dazu die 2
funktion oder die zweite variante von
das ist das als pronomen ein pro nomen
steht immer für ein nomen das heißt wenn
ihr ein nomen in einsatz habt und ihr
möchte das nicht noch mal wiederholen
könnt ihr stattdessen ein pronomen
benutzen eine möglichkeit hierfür ist
zum beispiel ein relativ pronomen so ein
relativ pronomen leitet immer einen
nebensatz ein und dieser nebensatz
bezieht sich relativ der ist quasi
verwandt mit dem namen zum beispiel hier
haben wir den satz das handy das janisch
letzte woche gekauft hat einen
verrückten klingelton hallo hier haben
wir also das handy hier sehen wir das
als artikel und dann nochmal das janisch
letzte woche gekauft hat das handy das
janisch letzte woche gekauft hat also
erstmal das als artikel und dann das als
pronomen denn dass er sich gekauft hat
dieses das bezieht sich wieder auf das
handy eine weitere pronomen form ist das
demonstrativ pronomen zum beispiel in
dem satz das ist geil
das ist klar hier steht dass das völlig
alleine und es steht demonstrierend für
etwas das kann man sich dann überlegen
was das ist das ist geil hat janisch
gesagt das heißt er redet zum beispiel
über das handy aber vielleicht auch über
eine situation und das kann dann einfach
eine situation oder reaktion sein das
ist toll das ist geil und da steht dann
immer dass das für eine sache oder für
ein ding auch die anderen artikel
funktionieren als demonstrativ pronomen
ich kann zum beispiel sagen der ist ja
doof oder die kann ziemlich gut auto
fahren das sind jetzt die dümmsten sätze
die wir gerade
gefallen sind also das steht als
demonstrativ volumen oder als relativ
pronomen das interessante ist im
englischen werden diese sachen
unterschiedlich übersetzt und das ist
für viele leute verwirrend dass im
deutschen der artikel und das pronomen
zweimal das gleiche wort sein können im
englischen wäre es zum beispiel will und
bett oder will und witz und im deutschen
sind das die gleichen wörter dass es
schon mal verwirrend für viele
deutschland jetzt kommt aber noch
variante 3 die dritte variante von das
ist das als konjunktion und eine
konvention die verbindet immer zwei
sätze konjunktionen sind zb weil denn ob
oder und und das ist eben auch eine
konjunktion und dieses das wird im
deutschen mit zwei s geschrieben mal ein
beispiel
janosch denkt dass sein neuer klingelton
der hammer ist dass sein kelten
wahnsinnig leid ist stört janisch nicht
dieses das ist also tatsächlich eine
konjunktion ist verbindet die beiden
sätze janisch denkt dass und das was
nachdem das kommt ist dann ein nebensatz
und in diesen nebensatz wird beschrieben
was ja mensch denkt das interessante ist
dass dieses dass die konjunktion im
englischen genauso übersetzt wird wie
das pronomen nämlich mit wet im
deutschen sind es hingegen andere wörter
also es sind wörter die auch
unterschiedlich geschrieben werden und
dass es dann ein interessantes thema
denn für viele deutsche ist das auch
verwirrend es gibt drei formen von daf
und diese formen die über sieht man oft
oder man denkt vielleicht nicht daran
welche variante von das habe ich jetzt
und dann schreibt man einen text und
macht das vielleicht aus faulheit nicht
oder weil man es vergessen hat oder weil
man einfach schnell sein möchte und das
passiert mir auch dass ich mal
vielleicht beim texten beim whatsapp
oder sms schreiben einfach nur ganz
schnell das schreibe ohne das zweite ass
und das passiert manchmal auch
professionellen journalisten heute zum
beispiel habe ich das noch bei der
tagesschau gesehen dass dort ein dass
eine konjunktion das mit nur einem es
geschrieben wurde
zum abschluss habe ich noch mal ein paar
sätze vorbereitet in denen alle drei
formen vorkommen
der erste satz ist panisch besitzt das
handy das er letzte woche gekauft hat zu
leise klingelt hier sehen wir also die
konjunktion janisch findet das dann den
artikel das handy und dann nochmal das
pronomen dass er letzte woche gekauft
hat bezieht sich wieder auf das handy
also hier haben wir alle drei varianten
und in ganz seltenen fällen kann man
sogar zwei pronomen in den satz haben
und dann einen verrückten satz haben in
dem man drei das hintereinander hört
vielleicht habt ihr so was schon mal
gehört nehmen wir mal an ich würde jetzt
an janisch handy stehen und versuchen
die lautstärke zu ändern und dann stehe
ich da und sage ich bin mir nicht sicher
was ich hier mache ich glaube nicht dass
das das ändern wird
da hätte ich jetzt so ein satz ich
glaube nicht dass das das ändern wird
also ich glaube nicht dass das was ich
jetzt mache das was ich ändern will
ändern werde klingt kompliziert hört man
auch nicht so oft aber ihr wisst jetzt
zumindest theoretisch gibt es auch
setzte mit drei das hintereinander
ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt ein bisschen
besser verstanden was die drei varianten
von das sind und wann man das mit einem
ass und wenn man das mit zwei s schreibt
wenn ihr noch fragen habt dann schaut
mal gerne hier unten in die kommentare
und stellt uns eine frage
wir beantworten die dann und wenn ihr
mehr deutsche grammatik werden wollt
dann schaut doch mal in unserer app
ceiling vorbei dort erklären wir jede
woche deutsche grammatik anhand von
interaktiven geschichten und ihr könnt
dort auch nach sprechen
vokabeln üben und ihr könnt grammatik
üben schaut mal rein bei unserer app wir
freuen uns wenn ihr dabei seid
bis bald